days things are about to get very
difficult for millions of british
families
glad to say the chancellor of the
exchequer richie suenak joins us now
thank you very much for being with us
this morning um keen of course to talk
to um next about next week very soon but
i just want to start off with ukraine
and it does feel like there's just more
relentless updates every day today the
mayor of mariposa is saying thousands of
residents have been forcibly taken to
russia
i don't know if you know anything about
whether that's true but is there an
update you can give us on the latest
you're hearing from ukraine
well i think as like everyone we're
watching these scenes unfold on our tv
screens uh it's horrifying to watch and
and we sit here in admiration for the
bravery and sacrifice of the ukrainian
people and i think everyone watching
should feel really proud about the
efforts that we're playing as a country
to support ukraine at this moment
obviously people opening up their homes
most recently to take in refugees but we
are also a leading country in providing
humanitarian assistance ukraine 400
million pounds we were one of the first
countries to provide military assistance
to them and again we've played a leading
role in organizing the most severe
economic sanctions something that i and
my team have also been working on
talk about those economic sections but
just on the refugee scheme you mentioned
it was last week that michael gove sat
in that chair and told me that today
would be the day we'd start to see the
first refugees arriving under that
scheme do you know how many refugees
have entered the country under that
scheme and are you planning on opening
up your home or giving a room so in
terms of the numbers what i know is
about a hundred thousand people over a
hundred thousand people i understand
have registered their interests and
those checks are going through now and
there's checks on both sides as michael
probably explained anyone started to
come yet though i don't know if somebody
started to come in terms of the visas
that have been approved my understanding
is about uh 25 000 have completed their
applications i think almost 10 000 have
been granted already with the exact
movements of those people i don't know
but those numbers are ramping up all the
time there's more investment in the
processing for all of that and i said
it's uh it's wonderful that we as a
country can can play a role in lots of
different ways are you joining the
scheme yourself i know i think everyone
will be helping in in the best way that
they can and so full of admiration for
those who can do that you know my wife
and i will be helping in other ways okay
um okay that's fine and so president
zielinski um has told russia today that
it's time to talk
how optimistic are you
that we could see a diplomatic solution
to the crisis and liz trust says you
think she thinks it may be a smoke
screen for russia to carry out further
atrocities after regrouping yes well
i've obviously defer to the foreign
secretary and her judgment on this it
encouraging that there are some signs of
talks happening that's obviously that's
obviously good but you have to have some
degree of skepticism about it given the
track record of these things i think the
most important thing is any any talk of
uh settlement must be on ukraine's terms
obviously
and the best thing we can do is just
maintain the significant pressure that
we are bringing to bear on putin but
also providing support to the ukrainians
in in the meantime that's the best thing
that we can do and said and the
ukrainians will take the lead another
thing that ukraine is calling for is
other countries to effectively
act as security guarantors for any deal
that's signed because obviously it does
feel as if russia is demanding they not
join nato for example so they want
security guarantees from other countries
to protect them in the future is that
something the uk would consider yeah i
think it's it's probably a bit too early
to get into the details of what the
shape of any agreement might look like
and again the foreign secretary will be
taking the lead on these issues together
with obviously the prime minister um but
i think the right thing now is that
continue to put maximum support on putin
both economically through the sanctions
diplomatic and also providing a military
and humanitarian aid to ukraine you know
that's what we need to do
they are they are displaying
unbelievable bravery and sacrifice at
this difficult moment we need to be
standing with them that's what we're
doing and hopefully you know putin will
see sense we primarily been very clear
we want to see him fail in this
adventure in ukraine the world has
spoken almost unanimously out against it
and and of course we'd like to see a
peaceful settlement but in the meantime
we need to keep up the pressure um as
you say we have seen this unbelievable
sacrifice from ukraine um i just want to
play you a clip of the prime minister
and i'm sure you know what i'm going to
play for you um it's a clip of the prime
minister at yesterday's conservative
scribbling party conference let's have a
listen to what you have to say
it's the instinct of the people
of this country
like the people of ukraine
to choose freedom every time
when the british people voted for brexit
in such large numbers i don't believe it
because they were remotely hostile to to
foreigners
it's because they wanted to be free
to do things differently and for this
country to be able to run itself
give you another example
do you think there are parallels to be
drawn between
the democratic vote to leave the eu
and an illegal
invasion of ukraine where thousands of
civilians have died no i don't think
those two situations are directly
analogous i mean clearly clearly they're
not directly analogous and i don't think
the prime minister was saying that they
were directly in alligators either he's
not saying that directly and i guess but
what he is saying the people of this
country like the people of ukraine
choose freedom every time and an example
he gives is brexit
i said those situations are obviously
not analogous right that one is a
democratic referendum in a country where
thankfully we're able to debate uh ideas
in in peace and uh
during the eu and
and that should be their right and
actually that's part of that's part of
the situation that putin finds uh was
for him he doesn't like the idea at all
right uh that idea of expression of
freedom but i think i said that they're
not directly analogous situations but i
don't believe the prime minister was
saying that they were either
you wouldn't have used those words
though would you i don't i don't think
the prime minister did either he you
know they are not they are not we just
listen to you
people draw their own exactly what the
prime minister said so so we're not
taking this out any out of context at
all and people and look people will make
up their own minds but i i i certainly
don't think those two situations are
directly analogous and i don't think he
does either so you agree with the prime
minister that the people of this country
like the people of ukraine choose
freedom every time such as brexit
i mean i do think people in this country
prize their freedom of course of course
they do and but there's lots of
different ways that they express that
whether it's through elections through
referendums uh another democratic means
right now the people in ukraine are
fighting for their freedom it's pretty
crass isn't it though to draw those two
things together i think no one can doubt
that the prime minister has taken a lead
globally in standing up to putin's
aggression that's not the question i
asked well i mean i think
there's nothing about that i mean he's
taken a lead internationally in
assembling a coalition of countries to
inflict maximum economic pain on putin
and he has galvanized opinion and and i
think he deserves enormous credit for
that so i don't think anyone could say
that he don't you don't
he's not absolutely focused on making
sure we can do everything we can to
support ukrainians at this time a fact
that's been acknowledged by the
ukrainian leadership actually um and you
heard that when when uh when the
president addressed parliament but also
more generally i think it's acknowledged
the uk has played a leading role the
prime minister deserves enormous credit
for that but of course these two
situations are not analogous and no one
is saying that they are um whatever
happens with the wall the world has
changed do we need to start to look at
increasing defense spending
well we we had something called an
integrated review a little while ago
which takes a comprehensive looks at the
threats that are facing our our country
and then sets out a plan address those
before you well actually actually well
it mentioned if you leave that review it
said that russia was probably the
biggest state threat that the uk faced
so in that sense you know credit to our
defense and intelligence team so have
the president to recognize that and
that's why we already have increased
defense spending significantly on that
you haven't
increased it
can i say if i could just finish this
it's important so just a you know year
and a bit ago at a time we're in the
midst of chronovirus for most
departments we didn't provide long-term
funding settlements the one department
for whom we made an exception because of
the circumstances was the ministry of
defense and they received a four-year
settlement an extra 24 billion pounds
over the four-year period that's the
largest catch cash uplift in mod funding
since the end of the cold war and will
ensure that we are not just meeting our
nato 2 target but will remain one of the
leading defence spenders in nato and we
did that before but once you take into
account inflation as the russia think
tank has said defense spending is
actually going to be falling in real
terms in 2023 and 2024. you say that
you've met your targets uh on uh the
percentage-wise but the 2019
conservative manifesto pledged to
increase defense budget above inflation
every year
if you look if you look in the autumn at
the forecast that were published with
the higher inflation in there what you
see is that defense spending is
increasing in real terms over this
parliament it's 24 billion pounds extra
and that was done before all of this
because we knew that we wanted to say no
more money for different spending i
think in general if you look at what
we're doing across public spending you
know we're spending a lot and the focus
has now got to move on to and i'm sure
we're going to get on to talk about cost
of living in people's taxes
so let's before we get into that
conversation you know i think probably
the last time i was here we're talking
about the amount of the government and
spending is going up quite a lot over
the course of this parliament an extra
150 billion pounds more being spent by
government on all sorts of things to
defend schools hospitals
i think what people want is say okay we
get that you're spending a lot of money
across the board we now want to make
sure that all that money our hard-earned
money is going to be spent really well
and that's my phone no no more money for
defense and we we gave lots more money
to defend 24 billion pounds but we did
it okay before everyone else um now of
course we talk about cost of living
there the uk has understandably uh
imposed sanctions on russia as others
have as well
can you level with people on what that's
going to mean for us here in the united
kingdom
so i know this is the number one thing
that people are concerned about and
people are working hard they're
struggling with the price of things
going up i get that i'm spending all my
time focused on that and i want people
to know and they should be reassured
that look i will stand by them in the
same way that i have done over the last
couple of years to try and make a
difference where i can but as you said
the actions and steps we're taking to
sanction russia are not cost free for us
here at home i can't pretend that it's
going to be easy that government can
solve every challenge or that i can
completely protect people against some
of the difficult times ahead but what i
can say is where we can make a
difference of course we will that's what
we've done over the past two years and
most recently you saw that with our
announcement to help people with energy
bills nine billion pounds 350 pounds of
support to people they'll get 150 pounds
of that in april so look where we can
make a difference of course we will but
i get that this is difficult how high is
the risk of possession
i think you wouldn't expect me to
speculate on that what i would say to
people is they should feel confident
about the strength of our economy
we're actually last year with the
fastest growing economy in the g7 and if
you look at where unemployment is we are
now back to the levels of unemployment
that we saw before the crisis of very
low levels record numbers of people on
payroll record numbers of job vacancies
so look the the fundamentals of our
economy are really good because we've
recovered well because of the actions
we've taken but look the outlook is
uncertain as you've said because of
what's happening in ukraine um i want to
get a bit of a sense of your sense of
spending priorities and i understand
there is only so much you can tell us
ahead of uh next week
fuel duty is an area where there's been
lots of speculation about should people
feel that there is action that may be
taken there yeah and i know it's
frustrating for you for people watching
obviously i can't comment on specific
things but what i would say is i
understand that i have a rural
constituency people are incredibly
reliant on their cars and this is one of
the biggest bills that people face so
watching it go up right and
we're all seeing that and when we're
filling up our cards i get that that's
why we've froze in fuel duty already i
announced that in autumn it's the 11th
consecutive year of fuel duty freezes
and that really helps people i know that
and of course fuel duty energy these are
things that people on lower incomes
spend a disproportionate amount of their
income on and it hits them particularly
hard when the bills go up and things are
about to get worse for them as well of
course because in april benefits are
going up just three percent inflation
were expected to be around eight percent
can you at least say
that you're going to be targeting
for your help that you can give the
people who are going to need it the most
yeah that's that's what we have done
over the past couple of years
i'm asking i'm trying to throw forward
yeah and of course as you can you know
also judge me by my actions and over the
last couple of years you'll see and all
the researchers published shows this
that those on the lowest incomes have
have actually seen the greatest amount
of support so there will be action you
think targeted towards particularly
those on low income so actually if you
look at what we've already done on
energy you mentioned energy which is a
good one i i i i i i acknowledge you
want to talk about your record but i'm
just aware of timings what energy this
is something about this is something
that's about to come in right and there
are lots of different ways that you
could help people with energy bills and
you're going to have racial weaves on
later so one thing that the labour party
said is that we should just cut vat on
on energy that is the opposite of
targeted and it would mean someone like
you or me who probably has a larger than
average energy bill would get a larger
discount well actually what we've done
is provide 150 pounds to 80
of british households four out of five
english households that is obviously
going to mean a lot more to someone on
low incomes as you said it's much more
targeted support and it will get there
much quickly so we're doing exactly as
you have said we've um talked about how
difficult things are going to get and
that you can only mitigate so much of
that
but of course this is the time you are
choosing to go ahead with tax rises in
the form of national insurance i think
it's been
um it's pretty fair to say that those
aren't going to be going ahead if you're
not going to scrap it should we expect
to see at least some movement on the
thresholds at which people start paying
these taxes i think you know take a step
back why why are we introducing a new
health and nhs and care levy it's
because i care deeply about the nhs and
i know that the country does as well we
were faced with a situation where
millions of people were going to be
waiting years to get the treatment they
wanted as we recovered from chronovirus
i mean i don't know we did the windfall
in the formula higher taxes i'll get
this second you know we didn't think
that was acceptable for anybody and we
wanted to address it and the team at the
nhs are prepared to work incredibly hard
to work through that backlog i wanted to
make sure that they had the funding that
they need and deserve in order to do
that and that's why we're introducing
this levy people can be reassured every
penny of it unlike all other taxes every
penny of this tax goes straight to the
thing they care most about thanks to the
actions of the health secretary they can
also be reassured that it's going to be
really well spent because we're making
sure we root out inefficiency and we're
reforming things and we're actually
announcing more ambitious targets on
that today doubling the nhs efficiency
target in partnership with them which is
great news
but yes ukraine has come along and it's
made things more difficult but it hasn't
changed the underlying situation that
we've got this monumental backlog that
we want to work through and this is
although it's a difficult decision i
think it's a fair way to do it it's a
responsible way to do it i just want to
show you uh the graph
the following graph now this
shows is from the ifs and it shows the
uk tax changes under different
chancellors anything above the line is
tax increases
everything below the line is tax
reductions and red as labour blue is
conservative so you can see you here
right at the end at rishi sunak
so in two years
you've raised taxes the same amount as
gordon brown did in ten years how's that
um
for a low tax economy going i guess what
that chart doesn't show is all the other
chancellors which ones and had pandemics
to deal with
right which one which one of those had
to introduce furlough which one of those
had borrowing higher than at any level
since world war ii
that's the bit that's not on that chart
and that bar on the right is a direct
reflection of those things which are i
think anyone would say pretty
exceptional or hopefully pretty
exceptional and that you know no one
lasting a pandemic to deal with over a
century ago borrowing had never been
that high since world war ii it's the
biggest recession we experience as a
country uh ever or the 350 years so
that's not on that chart either hoping
your bar is going to come down i do
think it will come down over time and we
started on that and i point people to my
comments at the budget last autumn where
i said yes have we had to make some
difficult decisions we have i believe
those are the right decisions there are
responsible divisions decisions for the
country's economic security going
forward
but those are done now and my priority
is to reduce people's taxes we started
at the budget and you talked about those
on the lowest incomes earlier the first
tax cut we put in place was on people on
universal credit they face quite a high
tax rate when they're going back into
work we cut that significantly it's a
two billion pound tax cut for millions
of people it will mean a single mother
for example working full-time on the
national living wage will be 1200 pounds
better off so that was the first tax cut
and my priority over time is to keep
cutting people's taxes get that bar down
and and and that's where are we going to
head um just finally will boris johnson
lead the conservatives into the next
election yes thank you very much rishi
soon act thank you
chancellor there uh talking us through
uh the details uh that coming up in his
uh spring uh statement now we are hoping
uh to speak to the shadow chancellor uh
rachel reeves i'll be honest with you we
don't quite have her yet but we will
bring her to you just as soon as we can
to try and find out
exactly what labour's position uh is
rishi sunak was touching on that
slightly uh in the interview i believe
we may have rachel reeves and thank you
very much for being with us we just
heard
from rishi sunak who was saying i hope
you could hear me rachel reeves
hello there you are excellent good news
so we just heard from rishi sooner the
chancellor effectively saying that
things are going to get difficult
and that he is not going to be able to
help or fully mitigate the cost of
living
crisis and
what do you make of what he had to say
well wednesday is an historic moment for
the chancellor for him to show whether
he really understands the challenges
that people are facing at the moment
because
as a constituent cmp in leeds west i've
got mums who are saying to me i'm
struggling to put food on the table i'm
now skipping meals so i can feed my
children properly i've got pensioners
saying to me
i'm not turning the heating on even
though i need to because i'm worried
about how i'm going to pay the bills and
for those people and millions of others
up and down the country
we need more than warm words from the
chancellor we need the chancellor to do
the things that will relieve that
pressure on the cost of living like a
windfall tax on the big profits being
made by north sea oil and gas companies
and channel that back into lower prices
for everybody else and as for the
increase in national insurance
contributions it's the wrong tax at the
wrong time that's going to take even
more money out of the purses and wallets
of working people
well let's talk about the
plaid rise national insurance and we
just had the chance of defending it
effectively saying that he needs to sort
out long-term funding for the nhs and
social care and that's specifically what
that tax is designed to do it feels like
i'm in some kind of parallel universe
where labour is arguing against a tax
rise for the nhs what's going on
well originally you'll remember sophie
the the chancellor and prime minister
said that the national insurance
contribution rise was to fix the social
care problem but we now know that
there's going to be no new money for
social care in this parliament then they
said it was to reduce nhs waiting times
but there's no credible plan to do that
in this parliament
and all the while we know that the
government are wasting billions of
pounds of taxpayers money just in the
last few days we've heard shocking
stories that 8.7 billion pounds
overspent in ppe procurement including
ppe that couldn't even be used by the
nhs and now the government are burning
it taxpayers money literally going up in
flames so you can't help wondering
whether this tax rise is to pay for a
black hole because of this government's
waste and mismanagement well either way
if there is a black hole in the nhs
doesn't it need to be filled for
whatever the reason is
in which case why national insurance
because the problem with national
insurance is that is a tax on work it's
a tax charge by those people who go out
to work every day and those people who
employ them some of the richest people
in our country who earn an income
through
dealing in stocks and shares or through
a portfolio of buy to let properties
they won't pay a penny more in tax with
the national insurance rise
that's not right it's not right that
ordinary working people should be
fitting the bill and we are the only g7
economy that is increasing
other moment taxes would you like to
need every penny
what other taxes would you like to see
increase
or do you think the tax burden is too
high well first
first of all sophie i think that this is
the wrong tax at the wrong time and in
the middle of a cost of living crisis we
shouldn't be increasing taxes you know
the chancellor keeps giving interviews
and speeches saying that he's a low tax
chancellor we'll prove it on wednesday
reverse this national insurance
contributions rise and cut vat on
domestic gas and electricity bills to
help people with the cost of living
crisis now look i know that chancellors
have to make difficult decisions you've
got to account for every penny of
taxpayers money spent but if you are
going to increase taxes you should ask
people with the broader shoulders to
make a bigger contribution this
chancellor is not doing this with the
national insurance increase rights and
that's why i say it's the wrong tax at
the wrong time
do you think rishi sunak should cut fuel
duty
so i didn't hear that question sophie
should rishi sinak cut fuel duty
if the chancellor increa reduces fuel
duty this week we won't stand in his way
but even a 5p reduction in fuel duty
will only reduce filling up the car with
petrol by two pounds so i don't think
that really
rises to the scale of the challenge that
we face at the moment which is why we're
calling for a windfall tax on the big
profits being made by north sea oil and
gas companies right now and channel that
in
with both a reduction in v80 from five
percent to zero on gas and electricity
bills but also a big expansion in the
warm homes discount because we know it
is families and pensioners on low and
modest incomes who are struggling most
at the moment with the rising prices so
that would be my priority but any
sensible measures to deal with the cost
of living crisis of course labour would
support those on wednesday i just want
to talk a bit about the windfall tax
because this is something that labour is
talking about a lot you clearly feel
that there's a public polling to back
you up but isn't there a real risk that
this could discourage investment in the
north sea at a time when frankly we do
need to focus on our own domestic energy
supply uh because we're trying to cut
ties with places like uh russia and
independence and our dependence on
places like russia for oil and gas
well when shell and bp and announced
their record profits earlier this year
at the same time they announced a big
increase in the dividend payments and
also share buyback schemes they didn't
announce big future investment programs
future investment but this is the point
this is exactly the point sophie with
the big profits they're making at the
moment they're not channeling that into
new investment instead they are using
that money to further push up their
share prices and we've also seen big
bonuses for the executives at these uh
companies so it's not clear to me
that these profits are being channeled
into investment but instead into further
inflating the share price when i first
said that there should be a win for tax
back in january we thought it would
raise about 1.2 billion pounds but since
then oil and gas prices have increased
substantially and that surcharge that
windfall tax would now bring in about
3.7 billion pounds the chancellor says
that money somehow is untouchable but
the fact is chancellors have to make
choices about who to tax and who to
spare and instead of
carrying on down the path that this
chancellor is going on he should look
again at labour's proposals for a
windfall tax and use that to keep bills
low for everybody else that would be my
priority as a chancellor i'm deeply
disappointed it doesn't seem to be this
chancellor's priority
um i just want to talk to you about a
couple of things that the child that the
prime minister said uh yesterday uh at
the concept of spring conference
um we played the clip of him speaking to
rishi sinak uh earlier but just to read
you his words he said the people of this
country like the people of ukraine
choose freedom every time i can give you
a couple of famous recent examples when
the british people voted for brexit in
such large large numbers i don't believe
it was because they were remotely
hostile to foreigners it's because they
wanted to be free to do things
differently and for this country to be
able to run itself now rishi sunak
defended the prime minister he said that
he wasn't trying to make a comparison
it's not directly analogous he said and
the prime minister wouldn't say that
either what's your take on what the
prime minister said
it is utterly distasteful and insulting
to compare the fight for freedom
and
the
aggression of the russian
state
to the decision to leave the european
union is insulting to the ukrainian
people who are fighting for their very
freedom and their very lives and it's
insulting to the british people as well
and if the prime minister didn't mean
that analogy he shouldn't have made it
and he should take those back those
words and apologize to the ukrainian
people and the british people for those
crass remarks he made yesterday
uh rishi sunak also made the point that
the uk has been really supporting
ukraine
and the president zelensky
has been very grateful for the support
that the prime minister has given him
and in the same speech boris johnson
said this about labor
do we want them in charge at this moment
do we want them running up the white
flag do you see them standing up to
putin's blackmail what do you make of
that
well i'm not going to take any lessons
from this prime minister about standing
up to the russians this is a prime
minister who on the eve of the invasion
of ukraine was whining and dining people
were close links to putin's regime this
is a prime minister who overruled
security service in giving a peerage to
now lord lebedev of siberia so i'll take
no lectures from this prime minister
he lacks the seriousness and gravity uh
for the moment and i would ask the prime
minister to apologize for his words that
are deeply insulting but to the people
of ukraine and absolutely ridiculous
about the labour party
uh rachel ruiz thank you very much
indeed for being on the program this
morning that was uh rachel reeves ahead
of next week's spring statement
well let's focus now on the situation in
ukraine we've of course been discussing
it this morning and there are reports
that russian forces have
bombed an art school in mario paul where
400 people were
sheltering according to the mayor of
maripo thousands of residents of the
battered city have been forcibly taken
to russia it does feel as if the news
coming out of that country is just
relentless at the minute and we can
speak now to one of those important
voices from ukraine uh we're joined by
the deputy prime minister ola stephanie
thank you so much for
being on the program we always thank
guests for coming on the show but we are
especially grateful to you we of course
can't say
where you are in ukraine for obvious
security reasons and but what can you
tell us and our viewers about the
reality of what's happening on the
ground
yeah indeed i'm here in ukraine on a
beautiful ukrainian land unfortunately
many cities and parts of ukraine are
under fire and nothing left from the
beauty we all just seen 25 days ago the
situation is growing more and more
severe as i've been telling for a
numerous time more than 15 days of this
resistance are the resistance of
ukrainian people ukrainian nations who
face severe attack basically russia has
committed nearly all possible war crimes
uh which the humanity has seen over the
second world war the number of civilian
victims is far
more than of those from the armed forces
of ukraine it is absolutely essential
that nobody is getting used to the war
with 10 we resist and we will go
stronger regardless any attempts of the
russian federation which has
failed so far in its majority
you say that the russia russians have
failed so far
but how much longer do you think ukraine
can withstand this
well uh
while we were saying about the enormous
bravery of ukrainian people ukrainian
nation ukrainian army and ukrainian
government uh it's something that we
would expect from the all
leaders around the world who's standing
for the values enshrined in the u.n
charter and that's why ukraine will
resist as long as it's needed to make
sure that no terror no massive murdering
no genocide is committed on this land in
the 21st century but it is absolutely
clear that an only ukrainian army and
only ukrainian president will not be
able to withstand it alone it's really
important that all political leaders
around the world from u.s to european
union and asia would stay united and
establish the anti-war coalition and
only these joint efforts will allow us
to prevent this massive genocide and
murdering in the 21st century so far
ukrainian president ukrainian army
leaves a space and a time for the world
leaders to get even more united and to
stop this aggression we will stand as
much as it needed
so you believe it is a genocide
i absolutely believe it and i am a
lawyer myself and i commit myself to
implementation of the decisions and
recently international court of justice
um national court of justice has issued
a very concrete ruling uh on the case of
genocide of russian federation against
ukrainian population and it has obliged
russian federation to suspend military
operation and refrain from any military
activity on our land
we know that the words and the rulings
and the orders mean nothing to the
russian federation but it's not
something i presume or anybody else
presumes this is the reality putin and
kremlin are the war criminals they
commit the war crimes and they do the
targeted attempts to attack ukrainian
population and you see it by the wording
on the net the notification he's using
so uh it's not a question it's it's
simply the reality we all face in the
21st century
another reality um a group of ukrainian
mps came to the british parliament this
week and they were speaking about what's
happening to women and girls in ukraine
and saying that they were being raped
and then executed by russian soldiers i
mean it almost feels too terrible to
talk about but it feels very important
to talk about what are you hearing about
what is happening to women and girls in
ukraine
you know in ukrainian government i used
to before the war uh run the file
related to gender equality and women
empowerment and of course the first five
days of war the horrible stories of
women's have heard about those women has
been raped for for hours and then
murdered about the mans and children who
have been killed the hospital druid
my tears were topless but now i have the
very strong aggression to make sure that
each and every military criminal who has
committed this crime is held to account
that's why uh we have more than two
thousand cases uh criminal cases
opened in our prosecutor's office we
have the permanent information of the
international red cross organization and
each and every soldier who has committed
this war crime by order or not will be
held accountable be sure russian
soldiers that we fix and see it all and
ukrainian women will stand for each
other and we will prevail
it's incredibly inspiring to hear you
talk like this it really is um
president zelensky has told putin that
now is the time to talk
how hopeful are you that there could be
some kind of agreement some kind of
diplomatic solution
well it's not it it is definitely not
the talking between a brotherhood nation
or a bigger smaller brother uh ukraine
is feeling absolutely open to any kind
of thought because we stand on our
values we are backed up by each and
every nation of ukraine each and every
citizen of ukraine and we're united as
never before so uh these talks may take
place hopefully they will lead us to
some result we're extremely happy that
many of the european nations like turkey
like israel and transatlantic nations
like israel and other countries has um
initiated and will show the willingness
to facilitate this dialogue of course we
utilize all of these opportunities and
jointly i'm sure that ukraine uh will
reach the agreement uh on the peaceful
settlement but also will be uh
uh the country who have the guarantees
of his security solid clear and very
well uh understood to everybody
guarantees of insecurity not only from
russian federation but from other
countries who has the word to stay in uh
in that situation
what could an agreement look like it
feels as if there could be some movement
on nato
would ukraine be prepared to give up
some territory to russia
absolutely not
ukrainian territory is a territory which
has been fixed into in 1991 within its
entirety and internationally recognized
buddha it's not only the position of
ukraine it's the position of the whole
world enshrined in the numerous
decisions of the u.n security council
including security council whether
russia is was standing so it's not an
option for discussion of course there
might be a room for discussion on the
reintegration of those 10 territories
who has been under occupation for the
last eight years a while uh there are
like a number of the red lines which are
uh the inexhaustibility to legitimize
anyhow the unlawful and provoked
military aggression on our territory
this is the red line for us and uh
speaking of nato uh as i'm leading the
native file in the ukrainian government
i can say that the
the feeling and the uh the political
priority is still there while the
ultimate element of the agenda today is
the is the ceasefire and the security
guarantee so far nato has not suggested
anything uh in the first and the second
uh element of this news from our side so
that's why we're looking for those
options which will ensure our security
and withdrawal of russian forces from
our territory thank you that's very
clear and just finally we've been
hearing some
horrific reports coming out of mario
paul and
shelters being bombed the mayor says
that
citizens are being forcibly removed and
taken to russia
what can you tell us about what is
happening in mario paul
mariupol is basically the the forepost
of all the tragedy and sufferings our
people are facing right now it's already
for the 10th day when the ukrainian
government with the support of the icrc
the red cross organization and you're
not trying to facilitate this process
while russians have tried to legitimize
the evocation of ukrainian people to
russia and belarus through international
organization where they were blocked and
it has been
recognized and absolutely a nonsense to
educate people to the territory of the
country who has started the aggression
on ukrainian territory so now they do it
forcefully uh
reaching the the level of people
suffering to the to the way that they
are ready to get evacuated everywhere
just to stay more or less out of this
bombing and the threat of their life is
less of course we call on standing on
the official information official uh
sources of information from the un icrc
ukrainian government who provide the
data on the agreed route for evocation
for ukrainian citizens who provide the
humanitarian assistance please ukrainian
people the people of europe stand with
us stand for the rule of law and do not
be subjected to manipulations from
russian federation
thank you so much for being
on the show and before we leave i just
want to give you the opportunity if
there's anything else that you would
like to say to western leaders um
you're the voice of ukraine for us this
morning so what would your message be
my message would be that uh be as brave
as ukrainian
and
utilize each and every minute of your
time while we're keeping the the peace
on your land to make sure that the
aggressor and the terrorist is stopped
we deserve it as a nation we deserve it
as a people and we all deserve it as a
europe
thank you so much for being on the
program this morning you're an
incredibly powerful voice for your
country so it's been very important to
listen to you thank you
thank you
well as we just heard it's more
important than ever to try and get as
clear a picture as we can of exactly
what is happening
in ukraine at the moment and especially
of course in those strategically
important areas of the south we were
just talking about the besieged city of
mariopol
odessa is another one of these really
critical areas uh at the minute uh in
ukraine we can talk now to our
correspondent nick martin who is in
odessa for us nick thank you very much
for speaking to us what is the situation
like where you are
odessa
sophie is as you just said is it's a key
port city and it is being very heavily
defended and fortified now um for the
last few days we've been aware of
reports of a russian military naval
buildup of warships on the black sea
coast just off of desert it's a sign for
the residents of this city that the
threat lurks out on the horizon but
thankfully uh this city has not seen uh
any anything in much wave of attacks
certainly nothing on the scale of mario
paul and mikhail just to to the east of
here but having said that
it is widely regarded to be something of
an inevitability that the conflict will
come to odessa it is strategically just
such a key port
for the people who are trying to flee
this war it is a long journey for a lot
of people we're at a red cross bus
station here in odessa this morning
these people from the odessa region have
come with their belongings packed up
into suitcases and they're now waiting
for buses to take them away across the
moldovan border to the west here now
some of these people are from odessa
some other from the wider region but all
of them share one thing in common and
that is they are just not confident
about staying here anymore it is just
too dangerous and everywhere you see
sort of acts of kindness this is the
local church putting some food out water
some crackers and some coffee and this
is what keeps these people going because
this is a very horrendous time for
people the un have issued some
astonishing figures about the amount of
people who are now
internally displaced in ukraine four and
a half six and a half million people are
now away from their homes cast out into
this country and a lot of them are
already trying to figure out where
they're going to live for the next few
months and possibly even years for
people who live in mariopol that is a
city and i've been seeing pictures
coming through for the last few days
that's a city that has just been pounded
and pounded until there is nothing left
the images are just so desperately sad
and today we've had reports that 400
people who were hiding in a shelter in a
local art school are now under the
rubble because a bomb struck that place
last night that comes after a barracks
was struck yesterday while soldiers
slept and a few days before that a
theater which was being used as a
shelter was struck and so it it's just a
desperate desperate situation and places
like odessa are kind of holding their
breath now trying to figure out when the
attack will come and how bad it will be
one thing to say though odessa is is a
very well defended city the other night
we heard that a russian missile had been
fired in towards where we were and that
the defense missile had been sent back
and exploded it that perhaps will give
some people some heart here about you
know well whether they can be defended
or not and they are looking at their
leaders politically uh they're looking
at their leaders like president
zielenski who from the very start has
tried to communicate with his population
via social media and that leadership has
filtered down to the regional
governments here look at the klitschko
brothers in kiev vitale kim uh in
mikalia on on social media every day
trying to sort of rally their own people
these political leaders regional
political leaders have become heroes in
trying to give the people here who are
scared some information about what might
happen where they can go for help and so
the political system here has rallied to
try and give support to these kind of
people here who have nowhere else to go
but what they do know is they are
fleeing war and they can't get away from
it quick enough
these people will cross the border in
moldova later today that is a small
country that is absolutely full if they
get to poland that's full warsaw all the
capitals krakov they're full and so it
is a refugee crisis like we haven't seen
since the second world war and sooner or
later europe will have to try and come
up with a long-term plan
in which to try and cope with this huge
migration sophie
thank you nick i have to say just
looking at the faces of those people
behind you
as you say holding their breath
waiting to see if what is happening in
mario pole is going to happen in odessa
packing their bags and waiting it's an
incredible incredibly powerful image for
us this morning so thank you very much
for bringing us
that update nick marcan thank you
we'll have more on the situation uh in
ukraine in just a few minutes as well
and talking about the military
side of things but i do have something
else to talk to you about this morning
as well because we're launching a new
program
later in the spring that i want to tell
you about it's called the take with
sophie ridge and it's going to be live
every wednesday evening at 9 00 pm so
this is an addition to
the sunday show and it's a chance for us
to take the political temperature
midweek react to prime minister's
questions earlier in the day
but the thing that i'm most excited
about as well is not just speaking to
government ministers and the opposition
parties and back benches but we're going
to be talking to you as well
this is the big idea and we want to get
your reaction because we're searching
for a regular panel of sky news viewers
to take part in the program and to give
us your opinions on some of the big
political issues of the week so if you
want to be considered then do please
email the take with sophie ridge at sky
dot uk it's on your screen now the take
with sophie ridge at skype.uk just
include a couple of lines about yourself
what your politics are any particular
interests you have there's more
information online at news.sky.com if
you're a bit nervous don't worry we'll
guide you through the whole process it
will be fine
also our weekly podcast is back if you
scan the qr code on your screen right
now you can find the safe router on
sunday podcast and then that will
subscribe you so it'll be in your feed
each week so there's going to be
highlights of the interviews bit of post
match analysis and also an insight into
how we put the program together so you
can find that and subscribe wherever you
get your podcast you can just search for
sofa ridge on sunday and it should be
available later today
back of course to the destruction
wrought on ukrainian towns and cities by
those relentless attacks from russia the
shelling and airstrikes on those
civilian areas has been a tactic
previously used by moscow and chechnya
and syria to try and break the will of
local populations the ukrainian
government has also accused the russians
of blocking aid supplies trying to get
into besieged cities and refusing at
humanitarian corridors we're joined now
by air marshal philip osborne he's a
former chief of defense intelligence and
a director at universal defence and
security solutions thank you so much for
being
uh with us we're
three weeks now into this invasion
what is the current state of putin's
troops
i think it's fair to say
um
they're
pretty demoralized pretty stuck and
they're pretty stalled actually
um they're demoralized because they're
reportedly prepared uh and they've been
proven to be
um inadequate i think that's putting it
mildly
um
they're stalled because they've lost
momentum so we're seeing them pull
resources manpower from across russia
even from syria
that's that's not a good indication for
a you know supposed superpower
and they're still because they're
running out of options
um and really what's left to them now is
to
is to double down on brute force um to
put pressure on the ukrainian government
you see this is the worry i guess isn't
it and that even if the ukrainian
resistance has been more than anyone
could have anticipated even if the
russian forces are demoralized
do you think it is brute force that
we're going to see more of
i think it is um
russia's tried to be
agile and that's failed it wasn't up to
it um so now it's faced with how does it
how does it get the ukrainian government
to settle
on terms which are far more favorable uh
to to russia to putin i mean this is all
about putin um and therefore the way
they apply apply pressure to the
ukrainian government
is to
you know level cities
um to bring in huge artillery um to try
and generate that humanity humanity and
pressure just not on the government but
also on the west
so
are you worried that putin could start
using
weapons that we don't usually see in in
these kind of fields of conflict um
chemical weapons for example even the
so-called like you know test of a
nuclear well how far could it go i think
i think we'll see more conventional
firepower first
um
russia has huge artillery stocks
and this is now a long drawn-out
conflict and they can be devastating as
well right exactly right um so
so we will see lots of conventional
but the risk of more unconventional
whether it be chemical whether it be bio
whether it be even nuclear that risk
must be higher um we come back to putin
does have doesn't have many military
options and there is therefore his
options to escalate on narrower and of
course this has an impact on how the
west responds
it does um
the west the west has got a challenge um
it has got to strike the balance between
trying to deter behavior
without
excessively escalating so this is a
really difficult tightrope to walk
but
but we have to be strong we have to be
resolute putin
does not respect weakness he sees us as
weak he sees us
decadent he knows every time he pushes
us we take a step back
so he would have been surprised by
the overwhelmingly strong sanctions that
have been levelled against him he'll be
surprised by the willingness of the west
to support the ukrainian government and
their armed forces
but it's not enough
so there's something about the west
needing to reset what it means about
strength and resolution
in order to deter further aggression so
what does that mean in practical terms
what do you think we should do
so there's a thing for the uk and
there's a thing for for the west more
broadly um the west needs to be
needs to be less trivial it needs to be
more strategic it needs to be more
resolute in the way that we've seen over
the last few weeks but we weren't seeing
over the previous 10 15 20 years
um i think the integrated review from a
uk perspective is a good start
um
but what this demonstrates is that
security isn't about sound bites it's
about doing difficult things and being
focused on maintaining those difficult
things so so the integrated review
yes is a good start we need more mass
and capability that's probably
more in the unmanned space probably
we certainly need more
digital capabilities and we and we need
really as a nation to be more resilient
um that's both physically can we defend
ourselves uh in the virtual space can we
are we good at cyber resilience but also
in in the way we are you know the
strength of our society what what do we
feel
the most important thing though is is
we've got to go quickly this
this is a wake-up call when we look at
the integrated review it has a 10-year
horizon that is too long do we need more
money it was interesting when i spoke to
chancellor earlier he was just talking
about the money that he had already
given to the ministry of defense and i
got the very clear impression that we
shouldn't expect any more
um
and the the chancellor will make the
decisions that he needs to make if you
ask somebody who did
uh nearly 40 years
uh in the uk military
um sinusoidal application of investment
is no good for it
so it needs
sustained investment
to allow us to protect the nation
but also from a uk military point of
view to take its part in a far more
strengthened nato
for germany to commit a hundred billion
euros in one year
i think indicates the scale of the
challenge that all western nations
followed and the uk i'm sure would want
to play as part
um i just want to
draw us back to the situation that we're
seeing unfolding in ukraine
the bombardment has been pretty
relentless and it seems that we should
expect more
of the same how long realistically do
you think the ukrainians can withstand
this um
they have been amazing
um but we need to bear in mind that they
they've been preparing for this this for
most of the west started three weeks ago
for ukraine this started nearly a decade
ago
so they've had time to prepare to think
it's that resilience that i was talking
about
um
they've also got a strength of will
and the application of good weaponry
which i think we're seeing
um frankly i think they will hold out as
long as
we can supply them and as long as their
morale holds up and those are two very
easy things to say
but really challenging to do but
focusing on supporting a brave people do
what's right for them has to be one of
those things that the west does to show
strength and resolution and president
zielenski has said that it's time to
talk he's called on russia to get around
the table and to try and find a
diplomatic solution and in the uk our
foreign secretary liz trust has
effectively said she doesn't trust
russia she thinks it could be a smoke
screen to allow russia to regroup and
then carry out more attacks
what is your sense about how optimistic
you are that any of these talks could
actually lead to some kind of solution
um i'm quite pessimistic in the short
term two things have to line up
uh ukraine has to be comfortable to give
something up
which to be honest with our interview
with the ukrainian deputy prime minister
she said that that was absolutely off
the table and you can understand why
that's the case because
thousands of ukrainians are laying down
their lives as we speak for that for
that sense of self so the
what is ukraine prepared to give up and
what is putin prepared to accept from
the perspective of a paranoid individual
until those two things get close
then there won't be an agreement
and i can't see those things getting
close soon
i understand the pessimism um that you
have
just finally ukraine is also asking for
other countries to effectively act
as security guarantors for any peace
deal so effectively if they end up
agreeing to not join nato and they sign
some kind of deal
they want the assurance that they will
be backed up if russia tries to invade
against the future or so on
do you think the uk should be prepared
to give that assurance to ukraine and
what would that mean
the ukraine has a security guarantee
already it was given in 1994 by the us
the uk and russia
and where are we now
so if i was a ukrainian i'd want to be
really clear that those security
guarantees were cast iron and more cast
iron than they were 20 years ago yeah um
those type of things i'm sure will have
to be part of a solution
but if i was a ukrainian i'd want to see
the color of people's money and that
brings you back to
resolution and meaning what you say not
going through the motions
really interesting to talk and thank you
so much for being on the programme today
thank
you
well that is it uh for this week sophie
ridge on sunday what a busy show in a
moment after the break we'll be running
through today's interviews and talking
about what we learned we're going to be
joined by our deputy political editor
sam coates thank you for joining us this
sunday morning we'll see you next week
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome to sophie ridge on
sunday the take where we'll be having a
pause to reflect and give some thoughts
on what we've just been hearing over the
last hour
really busy show today of course the
latest on that horrific situation in
ukraine it feels like with every morning
that you wake up there's more uh
terrible news to come out of that
country but today on the show we were
also focusing
on what is happening here in the united
kingdom because
clearly the sanctions that we've made
against russia are going to start biting
here in the uk very soon and that is on
top
of rising inflation and a cost of living
crisis that was already on the way so
things are going to be getting very
difficult for people uh next week rishi
sunak the chancellor is going to be
sending out his uh spring statement he
was on the program today along with his
opposition uh partner rachel lee's
reeves for labor so i was really trying
to get a bit of a sense on what we can
expect next week it's always hard with
these interviews because there's only so
much they can say of course before these
big
moment announcements but i thought we
did get a bit of a sense from the
chancellor
on a few of his priorities
and also of course about the
how leveling with people effectively on
just how difficult things could be
on the show as always we're joined by
our deputy political editor and sam
coats who i think i can bring in now sam
hello to you good to see you
um pretty i can see you're smiling away
as you always do on a sunday morning but
it was a pretty pessimistic message from
rishi neck wasn't it
it was i mean it's remarkable really
that rishi sunak ever since he was
appointed surprisingly in january 2020
has effectively been a crisis chancellor
um richie said like i think would cast
himself as somebody who was fiscally
quite conservative in other words he
likes uh to cut where possible uh be
that public spending or be that taxes um
and as you demonstrated very clearly by
showing him uh the graph of what he's
been up to over the last few years he
hasn't been able to do that there have
been
there's been the pandemic
now there's the war in ukraine um and
whether it's rishi sunak or his opposite
number uh rachel reese for labour you do
have to give them uh some breathing
space because the decisions that they
are facing the decisions that the
country is facing as a result first of
the pandemic now of the war in ukraine
are very very difficult uh indeed but
they are very important and as you say
on wednesday we get the spring statement
now
two weeks ago my sense from the treasury
was that this was a little more than an
update they wanted to uh
maybe sort of uh put the tilt the tiller
a little bit um steady as she goes they
weren't planning any great big
announcements but i think what's become
clear what's become horribly clear over
the last two weeks is that the pressures
on people are
just enormous on friday at the start of
blackpool spring conference
i left the conference to go to a soup
kitchen
there the person who runs it told me
that he set that up in order to help the
homeless now he was helping families and
people in work and the situation just in
the last month had got so much worse
because of inflation because of any
energy bills because of food prices this
is the challenge uh that the chancellor
has to tackle and as you say sophie i
think you did a great job getting
some of the hints some of the contours
of what we're going to see
on wednesday
in that uh in that interview but he
doesn't have endless amounts of money to
play with so the question is does he
live up to his promise to stand by the
british people the promise that he made
on your show just now
i was quite surprised in a way how firm
he was when he made that promise to
stand by the british people and he of
course many people remember was the
person who stepped in to directly pay
people's wages during the pandemic we
don't think we're expecting to see
anything on that scale
of intervention but i thought he did lay
some groundwork to do something and
we'll come back to you in just one
moment but let's hear a little bit from
uh rishi sunak um shall we and he was
trying to level with people i felt and
trying to say tell people that yes these
sanctions on russia are going to have an
impact here in the uk let's have a
listen
i want people to know and they should be
reassured that look i i will stand by
them in the same way that i have done
over the last couple of years to try and
make a difference where i can but as you
said the actions and steps we're taking
to sanction russia are not cost free for
us here at home i can't pretend that
it's going to be easy that government
can solve every challenge or that i can
completely protect people against some
of the the difficult times ahead but
what i can say is where we can make a
difference of course we will that's what
we've done over the past few years
well we can make a difference uh we can
he's obviously going to do something as
you say it was expected to be no more
than a bit of an update like talking
about the economic situation a couple of
tweaks here and there but it my
impression after the interview was we
are going to see some kind of movement
that's right and
i think where the treasury have sort of
been gearing up to do something is
perhaps help with the benefit system and
maybe to take the edge off that thing
that the government has chosen to do to
the british people which is the 1.2.5
national insurance increase on employers
and employees which is incredibly toxic
even within the conservative party boris
johnson has done it in order to try and
funnel more money into the nhs and then
eventually
social care but it's coming in in the
next few weeks just as all these higher
prices are going to hit
now the chancellor has a number of
options when it comes to what his
biggest kind of rabbit out of the hat is
on wednesday he could cancel that
altogether for a year he does actually
have the money that's about
nine or ten billion quid uh but i think
he would worry that it would just make
it harder to introduce the year after
and if he didn't do it then then the nhs
spending becomes impossible he could
just sort of uh deaden the the impact of
it for the less well-off uh or he could
do a big rise uh in the benefit system
for universal credit uh those are the
kinds of options um if he is being
moderately generous he will be spending
somewhere in the in the region of nine
or ten billion pounds uh which is only
as you pointed out uh
uh a sort of a quarter of the um 40
billion that uh he has to play with but
nevertheless i'd expect sort of
interventions on that scale on wednesday
otherwise he's going to come under quite
some far from his own side
for not giving sufficient help to people
thanks sam and one of the areas that he
is under pressure on is fuel duty we've
seen other countries making a move on
this for example france ireland they've
moved to give help on those rocketing
fuel
costs and it's always funny with these
interviews because you're trying to get
a bit of a sense tease a few newslines
out and my feeling was that this is a
man who is always very tight-lipped in
these uh pre-budget pre-spending uh
statement interviews the fact that he
talked a little bit about fuel duty and
his own constituency and he understood
how hard things were
that made me feel there could be a bit
of movement there let's have a listen to
what the shadow chancellor and the
chancellor had to stay on fuel duty
i have a rural constituency people are
incredibly reliant on their cars and
this is one of the biggest bills that
people face so we're watching it go up
right and
we're all seeing that and when we're
filling up our cards i get that that's
why we've froze in fuel duty already i
announced that in autumn it's the 11th
consecutive year of fuel duty freezes
and that really helps people i know that
if the chancellor increa reduces fuel
duty this week we won't stand in his way
but even a 5p reduction in fuel duty
will only reduce filling up the car with
petrol by two pounds so i don't think
that really rises to the scale of the
challenge that we face at the moment
which is why we're calling for a
windfall tax on the big profits being
made by north sea oil and gas companies
right now
uh labour they're saying that they
wouldn't stand in the way of any uh
movement or fuel duty and there's been a
little bit of pick up actually for some
of these and comments on fuel duty as
well this is the sun's uh political
correspondent natasha clarke she tweeted
wishes unite giving a bit of an ankle on
a fuel duty cut in the next few days
yeah that's definitely the impression
that i got as well um so we'll have to
wait and see just a few more days but it
does feel as if there could be some
movement uh there let's bring in uh sam
capes again shall we and sam
do you think that it's gonna be enough
to try and calm some of that bubbling
anxiety we're starting to see
among the conservative backbenchers
about
the hit
their constituents that is coming
no i mean if you even take just the fuel
duty issue
one of the reasons that richie's doing
tsunak can is because he gets more tax
money uh whenever uh the price of fuel
goes up uh walking past petrol pumps
yesterday uh diesel was up at 180 185 as
i was on my way back from blackpool that
is an eye-watering amount that directly
will translate into for instance people
people's fuel um food costs because it's
diesel that needs to go into the lorries
that brings people's food to their
nearby supermarket so there is a an
impact all over the place
and a little bit here and a little bit
there may well not uh
rise to the scale of the challenge that
people are facing and the big driver the
thing the treasury knows is that the big
driver
of people's bills going up these uh our
energy prices and that's the
hundreds of pounds that people have
gonna have to uh shoulder on their
energy bills coming in next month um but
the problem is that there is a
widespread expectation that on top of
the 600 or so pounds a year extra that
they're gonna have to pay from april the
crisis in ukraine is going to increase
energy bills perhaps by an additional a
thousand pounds we'll find out exactly
how much uh more the regulators think
needs to go uh uh the price cap needs to
rise by in august and it'll be
implemented in october but the sums
frankly in terms of household budgets
are unimaginable um people are losing
somewhere in the region of a thousand
pounds of their household income uh in
this coming financial year that's the
expectation uh entire percentage point
uh of their uh of their uh spending
money disappearing as a result of things
completely out of their control
and it when it comes to those energy
bills it isn't the case that people can
simply for instance turn down the
thermostat turn off the heating because
a big part of everybody's bills that's
going up are those standing charges are
either fixed cost bit uh that you can't
really do anything about that that goes
to pay for the insurance scheme that
kicks in when energy companies go bust
an awful lot of those have and for some
of those green charges there's a huge
political fight on many fronts and so i
don't think that the spring statement on
wednesday is the end of the matter by
any means
and i think this is just going to be the
topic of 2022.
thank you
sam it does feel you can understand why
uh rishi sunak uh perhaps felt uh
while richard perhaps felt slightly
aggrieved at the tax spending graph
because he has not only had to have this
cost of living crisis to deal with but
also
of course the covid situation too his
argument for his defense if you like for
why he's putting up taxes at a time when
people are feeling this dramatic cost of
living squeeze that sam coats was just
talking about is that they need to sort
the long-term funding for the nhs and
also
social care and so what is labour's
position do they agree with the taxes
that are due to come in in the coming
days this is what the show chancellor
rachel reeves had to say
but we now know that there's going to be
no new money for social care in this
parliament then they said it was to
reduce nhs waiting times
but there's no credible plan to do that
in this parliament probably in national
insurance is that it's a tax on work
it's a tax charge by those people who go
out to work every day and those people
who employ them some of the richest
people in our country who earn an income
through
dealing in stocks and shares or through
a portfolio of buy to let properties
that they won't pay a penny more in tax
with the national insurance rise
that's not right it's not right that
ordinary working people should be
fitting the bill
oh well let's bring in our deputy
political editor and sam coats i made
the point to rachel reeves some little
slightly jokingly really um that it's
strange to hear labour attacking the
conservatives for a tax rise to pay for
the nhs but it does feel as if we're in
slightly uncharted territory here
and on this
i know plenty of conservatives that
would agree with rachel reeves look up
in blackpool spring conference i
challenged jacob rees-mogg to defend the
national insurance rise he declined to
do so and say it was a matter for the
chancellor i've been talking to big
donors who worry that the money going in
to help the nhs isn't going to deliver
the results people want in that in this
parliament that's exactly what rachel
reeves just said so labour making an
argument but also punching a
conservative breeze
sam thank you uh very much we'll have
more from sam uh after the break because
we'll also be looking at what rishi
sunak had to say about the situation in
ukraine and of course the prime
minister's slightly controversial
comments to
spring conference yesterday where he
appeared to be comparing it to the vote
to leave the eu
the wind was like pulling us out of that
little room
[Music]
mandatory evacuation you must leave
i'm greg milam sky's u.s correspondent
here in los angeles
it is almost impossible to predict where
these fires will go next
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
[Music]
this gives you an idea of the strength
of those wins strong enough to bend and
twist metal
are you trying to run me over to fill it
no go away look like it sir
will you respond to those who made
accusations so philip can you go away
i've seen the dark side of america
we are standing on the supply line right
into the heart of america's opioid
crisis
[Music]
i've seen heartbreaking human stories
there was a river of blood coming out of
the mosque that's a scene that you don't
forget
christ church has been changed forever
by what happened
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm becca johnson a sky news midlands
correspondent based here in birmingham
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
[Music]
[Applause]
hello welcome back to safety ridge on
sunday the take where we have a moment
to take you back through the morning's
interviews and we get a bit of analysis
with our deputy political editor sam
coates um now sam of course was at
the conservative at spring conference in
blackpool uh yesterday there was a
couple of
controversial things weren't there that
the prime minister said on stage just
explain to us what he said and how it
went down in the hall
so yes we were up in blackpool yesterday
for the spring conference speech by the
prime minister and
he went a bit further than some expected
um he devoted a lot of his speech to the
conflict of incre in ukraine but as part
of that speech he was drawing analogies
between the freedoms that people want in
ukraine and the freedoms that he has
championed in britain and he singled out
the vote for brexit in that now
that has subsequently drawn a lot of
criticism from uh not just it has to say
i have to say political opponents but
also people inside the conservative
party one cabinet minister message to me
this morning said that they thought it
was inappropriate theresa may's former
chief of staff gavin barwell has also
criticized it to buy as hell which has
gone on record to criticize it so this
is called something of a uh of a
of a storm because people think that
that was inappropriate and then there
was a second thing uh that perhaps
raised even more eyebrows uh he alleged
that uh had labor been in power
then they would have uh basically
hiked up the white flag to president
putin essentially have surrendered that
was his allegation that of course
infuriates labour they have done a very
clear job of showing uh and saying that
they stand with the prime minister on
the action uh nato action against
president putin uh so many uh angered by
those comments too um boris johnson of
course has a habit of doing this kind of
thing uh but not everybody in his own
party likes it but i have to say in the
hall afterwards talking to activists
they were delighted with the speech and
this kind of stuff water off a
ducks back to the people who were in the
hall listening to it actually quite an
important point to make how how did you
go down with the activists there well i
did ask uh rishi sunak about his
reaction to what the prime minister
had to say about ukraine and then the um
brexit vote let's have a listen to what
the chancellor said
the situations are obviously not
analogous right that one is a democratic
referendum in a country where thankfully
we're able to debate uh ideas and in
peace and and
join the eu
and of course and that and that should
be there right and actually that's part
of that's part of the situation that
putin finds uh was for him he doesn't
like the idea at all right uh that
either of the expression of freedom but
i think i said that they're not directly
analogous situations but i don't believe
the prime minister was saying that they
were either
it is utterly distasteful and insulting
to compare the fight for freedom
and
the
aggression of the russian
state
to the decision to leave the european
union is insulting to the ukrainian
people who are fighting for their very
freedom in their very lives and it's
insulting to the british people as well
and if the prime minister didn't mean
that analogy he shouldn't have made it
and he should take those back those
words and apologize to the ukrainian
people and the british people for those
crass remarks he made yesterday i'm not
going to take any lessons from this
prime minister about standing up to the
russians this is a prime minister who on
the eve of the invasion of ukraine was
whining and dining people with close
links to putin's regime
all right rachel reeves are there giving
her reaction and we can bring in some
twitter reaction as well now this is one
of boris johnson's old adversaries i
think he'll probably unsurprised to uh
see the lack of support from david gork
the former conservative minister
campaigner for remain he said imagine
being a serious decent conservative mp
and having to go out and defend the
prime minister's ukraine brexit remarks
no wonder rishi sunak looks
uncomfortable that's the ration of
david gork well let's bring uh sam
coates back in shall we sam i just want
to
draw you to the very final question i
asked russia sooner because it does feel
to me like this
demonstrates just how far the political
landscape has changed in a matter of
months if not weeks i asked him will
boris johnson lead the conservatives
into the next election and he gave me a
one-word answer which was yes
do you think that any talk of boris
johnson effectively resigning as leader
or potentially a challenge from someone
like rishi sunak has that all gone has
it disappeared or is it bubbling away
still
rishi sudak said yes to you partly i
think because he's right the context has
changed for boris johnson's uh
predicament for his future he is safer
than he was uh a few weeks ago he also
said it because frankly if he said
anything else he probably wouldn't be in
the job of chancellor for much longer um
but rishi cena himself is in an
interesting position he dealt with the
questions about what boris johnson said
yesterday by basically asserting that
boris johnson didn't really say it or
didn't really mean it and and you could
see i think the discomfort on rishi
sunak's face this is not his kind of
politics this is not uh the kind of way
he likes to fight political battles
there were reports a few days ago that
richie sunak even considered resigning
at the heart of partygate uh aids denied
that that was the case but i know he was
deeply unhappy at the way the government
was being run the perception of the lack
of seriousness now that was partly about
partygate uh
pandemic rule breaking uh all the way
through 2020 2021 the about which we
still have more to hear with the police
inquiry and the sue grey report the
official report into what went on
but the question for mps really was
always can boris johnson be trusted
does he follow the rules and if he's
caught out is he straight with people or
does he end up as some suspect lying to
parliament now the war in ukraine has
completely changed the political
conversation and the context and you
couldn't have come away from blackpool
spring conference thinking uh anything
other than the people who were sort of
judged during an executioner of a
conservative prime minister those tory
mps and the activists that support them
in their constituencies are a lot
happier uh than they are but the bigger
picture questions will always remain
having had that damage done to him
having had those questions raised about
him is boris johnson plain sailing all
the way to through to 2023 2024 election
or to some of the things that led us to
that point keep coming back that's the
that's the essay question really sophie
i guess the other thing to throw into it
uh is the fact that we are about to see
a cost of living crisis that we haven't
seen for generations people getting
poorer and it's difficult to see a
situation where the governing party
doesn't at least to some extent pick up
some blame for that
that's right and when people get poorer
they justifiably look at the government
potentially get
more angry and i think
people in the good times might take one
view of their politicians but they
perhaps come to all together
more
less benevolent conclusions when they
are hurting potentially hurting a great
deal in the next few weeks and months
thank you very much for your analysis uh
as always much appreciated deputy
political editor
sam coates uh there well that is it uh
from sophie ridge on sunday uh this
morning a really busy show and of course
we've got a busy week coming up
politically as well with that statement
from rishi sooner how much support will
there be
from people in the united kingdom in the
united kingdom who are undoubtedly going
to be experiencing economic pain in the
months to come see you next week 8 30 am
sky news
[Music]
you